Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so a lot of you
are asked me to do video about Prometheus,
who is he so I'm going to explain that but
also how the show is spinning into a green
arrow rebirth arc for next season.
There's a new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on right now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break.
So there's still a whole bunch of questions
about Prometheus just because they have it
like rip the mask off and been like aha
it's you the person we been wondering
about this entire season so when arrow fashion.
I actually think they've already revealed
who it is in the back half of the season will
be more about their psychology in the way
the say like deathstroke slayed was unmasked
is the villain during the season to mid season
felt like season two episode nine and in the
back half of the season was diving deeper
into his psychosis like why is he doing this
like how deep has he sunk how crazy has he
gotten in what is it that he's going to do
to team arrow to the great thing I think they
did in episode nine is give you pretty
much all the information you need to identify
who this person is, but the reason I think
there's still a lot of questions people like
is it Tommy is it somebody else
that we've seen before is because like none
of the characters came out and said it's this
person and then you know like when they did
the slayed reveal show like the zoom in on
their face.
So because they didn't do that I think there's
still a lot of questions.
So they actually gave you all the evidence
you needed as team arrow was sort of like
jumping through the hoops trying to find out
who it is because before episode nine.
They'd already found out that it was somebody
who knew about the list when you that Artemis
had given them all.
This extra information about team Arrow, but
he already knew that Oliver was the green
arrow.
So a lot of that plays into stuff that will
find out about in the back half of the season
how long has he known that Oliver was the
green arrow at what point did he decide to
start training to defeat Oliver but we know
one that he was also trained by the same person
that Oliver was trained by, just because he
has the same moves that person is Talley all
cool like in the preview for episode 10 he's
talking to Diggle here in prison.
He says is a woman he's trying to track down
trying to she doesn't stand in one spot for
a walk outside she moves around a lot, so
she's really hard to find but he references
his time back in Russia.
So naturally because the flashbacks are in
Russia will see that play out over the course
the flashbacks that will also probably see
her of eventually in present-day so Talley
all cool very important to the Prometheus
mystery and you do kinda wonder like why would
she train someone to defeat someone else that
she also trained.
So she doesn't sound very loyal to Oliver
anything like that but that does kind of sound
in keeping with Talley's character will be
talking a lot about Talley on the back half
of the season but the next big thing is there
jumping through Prometheus hoops like learning
things during episode nine is that Oliver
finds a drug that reminds him of Justin Clayborn
way back in season one.
So is like I it's gonna be Clayborn, but I
killed him.
So you know what's the deal of the track him
down to Clayborn's old plan and find Prometheus
has laid a trap for Oliver and just messing
with his head so they still think it`s Clayborn
at this point than he sees his moves and is
like oh my God.
You know he must've train with Talia and they
get some ashes off of him and start to analyze
it but conveniently as they continue to pursue
this Justin Clayborn lead it takes the rest
of the episode to analyze those ashes like
the DNA and find out who it is the Prometheus
has been carrying around this whole time and
then they find it.
It's actually Justin Clayborn's ashes.
So Justin Clayborn really is dead, who is
Prometheus.
So, leading to the next big clue Billy goes
to Prometheus's office opens the safe and
finds a picture of a baby and also and just
as is able to send the picture to Felicity
Prometheus just shows up like a ghost captures
him and we know how the rest of the episode
plays out like dresses him up to look like
Prometheus.
So that Oliver kills him, just trying to turn
the rest of the group against Oliver like
Prometheus wants to destroy team arrow but
instead of just killing everyone like he tells
Artemis he wants Oliver to suffer so he wants
to destroy team arrow in the most excruciating
torturous way possible, both mentally and
physically and that's going to take the entire
back half of the season so really like the
other.
You know next big clue about who Prometheus
is is when he reaches the rooftop like before
he kills Billy where he flashes back to the
moment that he finally killed Clayborn your
Clayborn is very unrepentant.
He's like the of those people that were gonna
die didn't matter anyway Oliver gives in the
you failed the city takes them down that's
the end of it but in a flashback to present
day and Prometheus throws that is facing up.
Did you bat an eyelash when you killed and
did you feel any remorse did you feel bad
about it.
Tell me again.
I failed this city. You infected the people of lan valley to turn a profit.
You wanna make this city great again?
This is how with business, money.
You are sentencing  innocent families, children to death.
nobody cares about those people there a blithe.
I`m just thinning the herd
So am I
did you hesitate at all when you killed him or was
just another name you crossed off your list.
If you want revenge i`m right here. This is about
so much more than revenge.
So the only thing they don't do the episode
is attached a name to the who like they found
out that this is Justin Clayborn's illegitimate
son but they don't say this is his first and
last name that still the mystery.
So we already know who Prometheus is actually
in the Minnesota court records politically
was divorce baby is Clayborn son you told my Clayborn didn`t have any kids.
divorce petition Clayborn's ex-wife file says
otherwise is no record of the kids name the
files the date of the filing date maybe about
30 just old enough to put on a hood and a mask.
Old enough to want revenge on the
man his father I think in arrow tradition
the twisted self about the identity of Prometheus
isn't that complicated.
It's not so much about the who, it's about
the what he's going to do, to Oliver and how
Oliver's gonna deal with that over the back
half of the season that's really where it
seems like most of the writers energy is going
to rightfully so like.
The twist itself isn't that big of a revelation
like, Oliver killed the bad person but that
bad person had a family of his own.
Now they feel justified in seeking retribution
against Oliver for taking everything away
from them so that kind of goes back to Artemis
and the reason why she started to help Prometheus
because she felt like Oliver was being dishonest
and was actually hurting the city more than
he was helping it even though that's kind
of bull crap the producers did say a long
time ago that the show was built on Oliver's
mistakes like the way they wrote the show
Oliver tries to do something as a hero tries
to make his city better, but in doing so actually
causes a bunch of his own problems, the same
way that Barry does know most big heroes because
a lot of their own problems.
So even though we don't know the actual name
of Prometheus like and what is actual name
is he is Justin Clayborn's illegitimate son
it is that you know there's a so much about
his character that we don't know yet at the
reveal over the back half of the season it's
not so much who he is.
It just in explaining his character and what
he's been doing these last five years going
around and collecting all of Oliver's discarded
arrows and melting them down a reforging them.
That's a good crazy hard task to do he's been
plotting this revenge for a long time just
in the same way that deathstroke was plotting
his revenge against Oliver for a long time.
So, I know everybody's really excited that
the kind of back to basics season one season
twos style arrow with the way they plot the
episodes and how things are working so in
the way that the deathstroke arc played out
over the course of the back half of season
two I think a lot of the Prometheus art the
back half of the season will feel like that.
So hopefully this explains a little bit about
Prometheus like that who is kind of already
been explained just the stuff that we don't
know a whole lot about that they're going
to continue to reveal is the why in though
what part of what he's going to be doing,
to Oliver to continue his mission of just
completely destroying his psyche.
The other big thing is the what is this say
about season six like you know where is Oliver
going to get to by the end of the season if
he is able to defeat Prometheus while he was
going to do like reassert who he is like redefine
what the green arrow is what his mission is
is can be like green arrow rebirth, so to
speak it like that Grignard rebirth in the
comics so before you can have a rebirth you
sort have to tear him down so Prometheus is
going to be tearing Oliver down so that season
six can be a green arrow rebirth.
I think will deftly make it to season seven,
but beyond that it just depends on whether
or not the actors want to keep making the
show US can let me know.
Do you feel like season six.
You know after this Prometheus arc is going
to be something of a green arrow rebirth for
the TV show they got a version of the black
canary back.
Even though it's black siren that's can be
a lot of fun to see how that plays out and
what her future.
On the show's going to be because in true
fashion.
Like I think is Lapin with Prometheus to the
biggest villains never died they just go away
for a little while like a less you see a body
they're not dead.
So of course I think black siren can escape.
I think Prometheus is going to escape to really
what I want to see if they make it to season
seven is to have like a giant villain team
up sinistra core style for you to like the
one page teaser where you have like deathstroke
and every other big villain from the arrow
verse.
That's not a metahuman teaming up to take
down team arrow.
So I feel like Prometheus has been a great
villain this season hopefully they'll keep
him around in the future just in the way that
they kept deathstroke around to come back
and play with team arrow every once in a while
after his big arc is done this season.
Congratulations to this week's flash ring
giveaway winner King falcon please private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact details.
There is a new round that started in this
video I'll just remind everyone when I post
a new flash video this weekend so was can
happen tonight is I have new Star Wars episode
8 teaser that I'm in a post Kylo Ren was going
on and on about his character is going to
be so awesome.
So Kylo Ren Star Wars Poston tonight get hype
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for a new flash trailer and you
can click here to learn all about the plot
of Thor Ragnarok it just released the synopsis
think you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see in the next video!